all right what's up y'all it's Grady
dick first episode of Welcome party on
the bleacher report app I'm your host
I'm here with Brandon Miller Bill Bly
how youill I'm great man good great just
it's good to be here to see my guy gr
dick man I have't sh been all time in
the city thanks for coming out sure
manate yeah so I know recently we had
our
birthdays I was the 20th you were the
22nd how old are you I'm 21 big 21 2 the
big two congratulations [__] it man how'
we celebrate first you know we had a
nice you know ball game at home and
Charlotte uh did we win I don't think we
won so good though but I had a a nice
family dinner um I just went to the crib
I went to sleep
bro it sleep little calm you know
nothing too much with me oh Toronto
night I'm basic that dinner same thing
same old thing but yeah you're in
Charlotte now
so 6 months ago we're in the draft lot
has changed we're on podcast now it's a
new world how's it been adjusting
uh never thought we we would have just
us two on this podcast uh I mean it's
it's cool man just um it's a blessing
just playing you know every game that I
get um feel like it's a opportunity um
just to go out there and just
um you know hope you know all the great
players it's kind of a a blessing just
to be out there and you know really just
have fun you know what we do um and the
sport that we love so definitely well I
on your draft day little before I guess
you're getting text from lamelo is that
true the big drop the ball he knew yeah
man I don't really know if he
knew uh I I had some weird experience
that night uh got pranked calls some
more so it was all over the place that
night just there was just all kind of
bad that night prank call they told you
going
somewhere said New Orleans traded a
traded for this Charlie Hornet so I'll
be going to New Orleans they sell it
real no they didn't after the
conversation just it just just hung up
so I got one call on him he sounded
official he said you're going here you
know what I said thank you
sir I did I did I'll be honest but after
talking to some agents it was fake but
anyway yeah speaking of Lelo going back
to that you know I know he's out for a
little right now but what's have been
teaming up with him you know he's great
um I think just with his IQ um his his
ability to you know make plays um you
know pass and plays um you know his just
ability to lead as a point guard is kind
of uh a good thing for me just coming in
as a young guy I mean he's not that much
older than me but uh but I mean he has
more exper experience so it's kind of he
knows more about you know the NBA game
than than I do so it's kind of you know
easy just learning from him and all the
older guys yeah yeah for sure I know
that's a a ton of learn from you know PG
like that fun way to play um any good
advice he dropped on me
uh advice is crazy no no but uh I know
he's he a motivating guy so um he's
always he's always um Paul's only but
you know so it's just that right what's
your funniest moment with him you start
to you laugh when I bring up his leg
funniest
moment
uh I can my most favorite player with
you know the have C Lobby J for the
moment we don't have it no funny
moment nothing in the brainstorm can't
think of nothing no no no that's it's
not a good brain star think about good
m whatever let you keep it off camera
anyways you know you hear guys talk
around the league um coming into league
for the first time they're welcome to
League moments and one of mine Jayhawk
Jo gave me a little nudge whatever Rock
chock so what's anything like that for
you but where k
at you know I haven't had any crazy
experiences yet I haven't been haven't
been dunked on crazy uh it don't have to
be like negative it could be like
walking to Arena
the first time you never been there of
course first game I was nervous yeah
like when I started it's it's kind of
different you know just coming off the
bench um you know I just here for my
teammates here to do whatever I can just
to you know um affect the game um and
just go in there and try to bring out
wins um to you know to to another ball
game that we come into you know I can be
for sure ner I can you know go into a
new arena for the first time defin
nervous meet new people many people
there too many there too many yeah no
it's cool that when you first go in kind
of go for the pregame shooting and no
one's in there that's kind of like what
I like the best because it's you see
full
size yeah I think you know my my shoo
around times is usually pretty early so
nobody run the in said kids number one
journe off that's what it's all about
really but no that's you know big
moments like that big people you know
watching your games you know MJ I heard
you a little back and forth with him
Little B little Trash Talk um he always
asked me if I can pom a ball knowing I
can pom my basketball but you know I
still got one up on him I said I did see
him airball at free throw so um just to
think about Michael Jordan airball in a
free throw it sounds crazy but it remind
Brandon Miller witnessed it bring back
down to earth definitely witnessed it
but yeah know guys like him oh biggest
name to not even basketball all the
sports but um other guys with the with
your team you know Jay Cole you know
he's part of it now
so I mean you played him yet I have not
played him uh I remember he came uh came
to one of the games uh said court side
then I didn't realize who he was until I
seen all the hair yeah right there had
to get it had had to meet him uh I he's
a great guy um he's not really I think
he's probably the same as
us if you were to play him though you
blocking that up or you scoring is he
scoring on you be
relistic
be get
lucky get lucky it's crazy now
he I got the score prediction if we're
going to 11 probably 11 to three was
three so so he's scoring I give him one
you gotta give him one you know can't
let it get too bad I like that I like
that but no yeah I know we're talking
about justing the league different
things like that um more serious note um
you know one of those things where it's
it's kind of the intricate parts of the
game I feel like that's adjusting the
league of maybe realizing the space on
the floor is different obviously from
college um so what's kind of some things
you say different from college that
you've
noticed um I think the most thing that
stands out about NBA basketball and
college basketball is definitely defense
of three seconds I think college Bas you
got the the presence of the seven-footer
down there so I mean you going into pain
on you might you know have to make a
drop off play uh I think in the league
you know you have the late low man so
it's dunks after dunks layups after
layups kickout open threes uh yeah so I
mean I think it's really just playing
with um I think it's a confidence thing
uh you know just coming in as a rookie
playing with you know the space that
that we have on the floor um I think
it's incredible actually just with older
guys like no Terry uh Melo Gordon um all
great guys to play with u you know just
been on the floor right there when
learning from him it's all great yeah
for sure and reverse that what's the
different you you watch college games
now you know watch your your boys back
in B but know you you see things here
and there that's a little
different um yeah it's definitely
different at uh at B now but I think I
think as a as the season go on I think
they did they you know click
and yeah find it find the right place of
course yeah so you know that was some
good knowledge good little adjustments
on on College you know compare compared
to the NBA but um you know I wasn't
there last time but um you guys got us
you know in Charlotte when we play the
RS but you know how how was that it's
definitely fun yeah scari Barnes out
there talking you know talking his cash
as always um Scotty gonna be Scotty
Scotty gonna be Scotty um as far as you
know everybody else um I think it's just
a hard competitive game um everybody out
there having fun um just trying to win
it's always always a safe matter of
course of course you know we guys got
you tomorrow um seven play all at seven
7:30 7:30 TR to change that around a
little bit but you know after that you
guys got some you know bigger teams with
some bigger names you know coming up um
you know the Mavs he bucks some some of
those guys so uh what would you rank you
know out of those teams kind of the big
names or the matchups coming up I was
definitely um yeah we definitely got a
tough schedule uh coming
up I
think I think the tough team is is
definitely going to be the the heat just
because I mean discipline uh they always
in the right places on defense uh they
force a lot of turnovers um you know
Jim's a great player I think think when
he gets in the post it's kind of it's
kind of
Unstoppable I remember first game we
played them um hit and shooting I one
three against us he made all midwe was
just just pretty crazy so yeah know
speaking of him you know being a new guy
you know making an impact like that
early is you know incredibly impressive
um any other like newer guys or or I
guess guys you're surprised that are you
know making you know big impacts in the
in the league we just played in be it
was pretty
nice it was pretty nice uh I don't
remember him missing a shot honestly um
but big physical um score all three
levels um I mean that's that's it right
there definely you know seeing yeah we
played them early so I think that was
like seen a player like that for really
one of the early moments and seeing a
guy of that nature just go off like you
said hardly miss a shot how efficient
doing
everything and his size is is insane you
know shooting three he Duncan so I think
that was yeah one of the early moments I
was like yeah yeah they're Pros we're
Pros dud but that's yeah definitely eye
opener but um yeah you know your games
have been I'm pretty solid had say least
no solid do my best I do my best
speaking of best know you had an alltime
high against the Knicks he dropped 29
I'm
sturdy I would say St you knowed as well
30 round it up no I think that game it
was kind of Click kind of early um I
don't think it was just offense I think
it was kind of the whole game know I
think that I think our defense kind of
brings us energy um towards the the
offensive side um to know we didn't pull
out a win so yeah it would be great if
we beat them you know next I we play
them no counsil to win but 29 Points is
good it's good great it feel different
it just just goal is bigger everything
how do it feel just nonstop buckets I
have no honestly man my goal is just
year just try to win as many games I can
um I don't think I think personal goals
will come as the season um goes on but I
think just the main goal is just to win
as many games as we can of course
playoffs for sure definitely need to get
there yeah for sure and you know going
back to you know guys like Joelle know
you had the Bucks another big big star
with Giannis I was I was definitely I
was trying to get a charge on y I'm
trying to get a charge on all the um
Pros here um still waiting on bri trying
to get the charge on bri um so I think I
think that that'd be a good
accomplishment I have under my belt took
a charge against I got one charge know
who
was
yis my one charge against Yannis that
was definitely a welcome to leag moment
I guess I bet it was I felt that I bet
it was next week but no yeah but yeah no
you guys already played the bucks um
like like I said um I have a question
regarding the Dilemma you saw between
Giannis and the game ball him running in
and trying to get the ball back um what
are your thoughts
on let's just put it like this like
let's say he has a 64-point game on the
other team they got their first bucket
first career bucket who gets that ball
I know I understand Giannis is you know
Giannis I you know if I was a rookie I
would definitely give him the ball too
because you know he just broke records
um but you mean I mean you can always go
another the game ball you there got be
two see well the ball goes on the
STS the real one the fake one is still a
game ball I'm still taking but no
understand I understand his emotion
though I was just asking that but I got
to thing too because it's like like it's
your first ever NBA bucket it is dream
come true and someone just so happens at
64 points
so I don't know Dom they should had him
62 points he deserves it for sure
obviously
but first bucket um but no I was talking
earlier about your three- game stretch
messed up a little who cares it's
actually the Clippers Lakers and the
Suns so I big names too obviously you
know big names around the league but
um obviously you're you're dude PG PG
you're goat that's definitely Yeah I
broke the media with that one that they
like that one no that's definitely been
one of the matchups I've been waiting on
uh definitely PG just because of course
is my favorite player growing up watched
him my whole entire life
um R my game and his uh so it's kind of
a exciting moment just you know being on
a cour where you know your favorite
player um you know hopefully I can trace
some buckets with him you know of course
you know that'd be a special moment for
sure but yeah like you said you compared
um your play style some of your moves
took some of his moves um what's that
like you know in the in the gym you know
alone you're trying to take those and
kind of add your own twist to them or
definitely just copying no no no not not
exactly copying you know just copy a
little bit putting my own twist to him
um it's kind of like my own little swag
to him um not really steing his whole
flow um but you know we have a few you
know a few moves that's that's exactly
alike um as far as
crossovers um I don't think he's up high
as
he got that on him yeah I think I got
bounce young legs 21 year
old but no yeah I heard on that podcast
you know you guys exchange numbers my gu
got that info um take him up on the
offer you talk some little little trash
in there about your game coming up up
proba night before Oh No Trash Talk No
Trash Talk you start that with him yeah
have you Le
yet like have you directly went at
someone on
purpose no but I have had you know a few
you know tried me a few games you know
Detroit um last game but it it was you
know they personal offit court it's all
love uh you know after the game you know
just dapped up it's just Hoops congrats
congratulations yeah know for sure cuz
it's I think that was probably the
biggest advice um you know they kept
repeating where the new guys come to the
league they're going to go at us so it's
one of those things where you
know yeah they're just GNA you know keep
going but yeah not retaliate but not
gonna P your ground your like that's
what I did I white grow definitely all
right anyway we went not talk little
back to PG what's we're going to go one
word describe his game describe his
game do you have it in your head I bet
we got the same
one Buck
it I say smooth smooth I'm
smooth what I know what I want no I just
I'm smooth you know every chance I get
smooth every chance I get
um yeah so two days after that game the
Hornets got the Lakers I hear her saying
on the interview that you're excited to
play against LeBron but he I guess is
not your goat PG is so why are you
excited to play LeBron you know he's in
the the conversation of you know one of
the the goats um think he's in well I
know he's most definitely in the
conversation with you know Jordan um you
know all the guys so I think just you
know being out there with him on the
court um hope I don't have my my rookie
moments against him uh definitely G on
every social media um you know just BR
can go out there make it hard for him uh
make shoot over a contested
hand he makes it he makes it get a good
picture frame it yeah but no yeah that's
good that's good now he's been a league
a minute you want to play that
long I want I want to have a career in
the league um 10 years plus um was
Bronze Age that yeah know because I know
some guys they want to they kind of have
a set that's your account of what they
want to do or that's hard on the body
just play as long as you physically can
I don't know I don't know how you do it
that's a love for the game for sure um
but yeah we got one word to describe PG
plus one word to describe
bra
physical
physical physical every time he get it
he's driving using his body get all kind
of bumps and ones uh he's on the line
then that's definitely a 40 point game
yeah for sure Tak Char well definitely
taking
Char anybody yis no no bra who
bra bra for sure bra
Yannis
I don't know because I just seen Zion
Zion you know I thought Zion was taller
Z like 67 66 don't matter but Zion is
Big I'm still doing bra still doing sure
just so iing I took a Char on BR I to
after that got ktie and the Suns moving
on know you hear a lot of people
comparing you two especially Chandler
Parson said something about um
just your play Styles you know your
frame not necessarily the height but
what do you what do you take from that
you agree with that to a Kevin Durant oh
do I see I don't know about KD uh I
think KD is more of a
um just a score um definitely a Athletic
score for sure um I think he he does a
great job just getting to his spots um
and just rising up over you know
Defenders
um but I think why I compare myself to
PG is just um his allaround game uh
plays defense I think that's one of the
things I kind of um you know recently
got motivated to do uh maybe more just
to go out there and get the the stops
that we need um and all the effort plays
as far as you know taking charges um
diving on the floor um know you know
being an energy guy just to you know
bring the energy um to the games that we
yeah yeah I feel like it's I don't want
to say more realistic to be compared to
PG but it's because there obviously
nothing normal about him you know he's
insane but um KD 610 he does I don't
know who does who really does compare to
that but um for sure you know we did the
first
two uh what do we do with
the one word one word to describe KD
oh
I already used bucket can't use bucket
again but Katy is a bucket
unicorn
unicorn we gonna use that one
unicorn all right all right we're done
with that all right I'm curious to know
what NBA vet would you put on a
2v2 against me and mine I got Larry
MD
shooters GRE big La bir
okay
um I don't know I think I might go to I
think I might go a footer a footer yeah
s footer who I have no clue let me think
about this one though it got to be a
vent yeah like someone's not in the
league right
now NBA history Legend but are they Prim
yeah you yeah who were SC
Jordan Jordan Jordan not a basic answer
du or Duo might be crazy good to
man just don't know who screening and
who
rolling SC it's really
oh start to
Larry yeah no away from basketball
actually let's let's move to a different
topic for now you grew up what sports
did you play baseball football and
basketball baseball and
football pitch you pitcher okay I know
you had your first pitch at your
baseball game I have it was a terrible
first pitch that definitely would have
hit the batter it would have hit him
yeah for sure mine was thought mine was
pretty legit I definitely seen yours I
was a short stop but I pitched a little
back in the day six seven the short stop
for the high school
team why you stop playing pass that fit
CU that's why that that's why you get
the ones that cut off I don't like those
that mean you got to wear the that mean
you got to wear the high socks with
those was the nervous for you like
seeing the backdrop because I feel like
when I got out there when I got out
there it wasn't that far were you on the
M I didn't see no I did I wasn't I
didn't want I didn't want to mess it up
it was they just had know the white on
it so I was like yeah a hole
Yeah fur it's further than what I
thought
it definitely is no that's like I got my
head got sweaty I I just made sure it
went over the plate little for seam over
you know not of the strike zone but it
made it to the catchen no yeah at least
he caught it that's literally the only
thing but I heard a big deal T 700
mil does that make you want to put your
kids into baseball instead of bball
um I think I don't know I don't know I
think it sounds you know crazy um it is
but crazy actually
but no annual salary I think I think I
think a lot of baseball players
contracted their actually GNA look like
that in in in some years it's theane the
amount of games they play though that's
the talk about difference in college and
NBA the amount of games 82 games and how
many games you played in college like
third around there 30 something if
you're lucky I'm on game 20 right now
and you get the mar
madis I'm on game 20 right now and it
feel like we done with a college season
exactly I mean it's a lot of basketball
and mean you play you know back Tob
backs uh we just had a back toback
Friday and Saturday against two great
teams
um know unfortunately couldn't get know
win yeah I think that's just kind of uh
I think that's just the NBA to just got
to move on to the next game um just go
out
with you know more energy that you
brought in the last game yeah I mean
that's why people in the NBA make that
money you know how many games they play
you know what they put on their body
stuff like that um would you see NBA
player make the amount of money that MLB
player like aani would make who would
you say R Bron in Dubai bra for sure
Braun's Somewhere Over The Waters yeah
what do you think over
700 it might be it
might yeah it's a global
name and Bri got other stuff too so it's
a little bit more that's yeah I would
say so football you got the NFL team I
don't uh I'm from Nashville I don't
watch the
Titans don't
oh Derrik Harry cool you know spam a guy
uh Rock the B guys know my guy Bryce
plays with the Panthers uh
Tu Jaylen all those guys you speak with
any of them that are still at B right
now because I know they just beat
Georgia they're in the they're in the uh
roseb now going to it
um who I talk to I talked to Jaylen Moll
QB QB
RB uh I mean that's it's kind of only
guys that talked to him in the
basketball team yeah I heard there's
yeah speaking of the Rose bow they got a
little dilemma with Florida State you
hear about that I know Florida state was
undefeated so okay get this Florida
State's
undefeated you know Alabama lost some
but basically they won that CC so that's
you know amazing for college football
and they made it but Florida State
didn't does that make sense see I'm
always I'm always going to stay on B so
you know yeah B definitely you know
coach should definitely be in that four
Florida State it's it's a tough good
luck good luck next year you're
undefeated but you won SEC the best
conference luck next year but no yeah
they got Michigan coming up who's
winning Michigan oh B Michigan Bama for
sure Bama got rock with the B boys tide
always roll way from MLB way from
football cars I knew it see you dried a
Mustang yeah I did in college boo M part
or no
car you like
Chargers Love Char man love Mopar all
Mopar uh I drive a nice Dodge Hellcat
purple on outside peanut butter insides
PB andj is the a you got a little I saw
your name suggestion to was that in
college or you still got that oh my in
my stars
you say me say my go my says I got a
little speaker system you know what it
says on the
plate my name Grady no no just Grady
just the last name and then just the
studio or just the what do you call them
subwoofers and it bumps and the window
Shake
I just got to get stars on the roof
that's all I
want I don't got to like you yeah you do
but it's all right got one day hey and
need this and it just magically happens
you know it change them this you know
what was your I know the I experience is
kind of crazy in college away from Cars
you have any other you
know you
got no I think it was just I mean in
college went to like all the other uh
sporting events like wheelchair
basketball um
softball women's basketball football
that all the football games I think
that's that's something people don't
really see I mean because when you think
about I people are seeing obviously
we're talking about cars I guess showing
that off but they don't see like the
charity stuff that like goes in the nil
that's actually pretty cool about
college and not even college but just
the marketing stuff in the NBA too that
we get to be at um those different
things the football games were the most
fun for me definitely especially at B
yeah top school in the nation Nick
saving speaking of Nick I he got a
little Ferrari he do his uh he got a
Ferrari dealership that's like 10
minutes away from my house in
nille I need to I need to tap in with
him
soon
soon I see if I can fit it you could
drive that in college why don't you just
text him no I couldn't drive that in
college sorry bu I don't know if I could
put a car like that in Lawrence
Kansas you think I can put that in
tuscal no no no no T no all right we got
a game we're gonna see if you can name
one through 14 lottery picks first and
last name in order oh we got we got a
little I mean I guess it's a hint we got
the teams ohos I'm G need that one cuz
we got the first
10 see if you can do it number one
Victor number two brand Miller scoop
Henderson Thompson
twis was it is it a men a men a men you
know him got cool
hair
Orlando Anthony
BL p
[Music]
jar was it
jarus where you at Pacers Indiana pretty
sure it was Jerry it wasn't jer's it was
a little thing going on when that
happened starts with a
B stopping
there that's all you
got all right no we're not going anymore
because that's all you got is terrible
so who so who was
it
oh he knew that and then J nice so I
guess they swapped him
too yeah not too shabby but I mean
that's about it that's all I got for you
today it's a wrap first episode of
Welcome party grats I'm being the first
guest thanks man thanks for having me
man appreciate you my guy I'll see you
tomorrow of course man you bust that
[Music]
ass